robert what is going on i mean i got a
lot of different data they
did they pay the four million dollars to
5 million to hackers biden's refusing it
happened this is the largest
5500 mile canola colonial pipeline
i'm in florida right now it got hit many
different states got hit what can you
tell us about what really happened here
well i don't i can't tell you exactly
what happened because i don't you know
work for the company but
you know it sounds like they were hit by
ransomware
and if you know anything about
ransomware uh
they um basically lock down your systems
and
tell you if you don't pay we're not
going to unlock them and not only that
we're going to delete all your data so
that's enormously as you know valuable
to a company so they'll pay almost
anything
to to get that unlocked and it sounds
like that's what happened here
in this case so is there a formula for
ransomware on asking the right amount
money to get where the company is there
do you know i was a formula
well you know um i don't know if you
remember the the hijacking of ships that
was going on near somalia
but um there was a they knew you know
what the cargo was worth they knew
how much the company was insured for
they knew so
it was a calculated business decision
and when they negotiated with
the hijackers in somalia i mean they
knew their business
down to the penny so i would imagine the
same thing goes on for these
um for these hackers they they uh
understand the the nature of the company
and then they basically figure out what
they can extract and and i think
for them um it's it's not like um
just a smash and grab it's a calculated
business decision so
uh in many cases like in the cases of
the smalling hijackers they had funders
so they may these guys may even be
funded by somebody they've got bills
they got to pay
i mean this is a business for them and
unfortunately we've created this
vulnerable infrastructure that allows
these businesses to thrive
how how much is this is going on right
now are you seeing a lot of this take i
mean obviously this has been going on
for a while
but the tactic then approach probably
has changed are you seeing a lot more of
this happening today
no i don't think it's anymore i think
it's just pervasive across
industry um one of the things that got
me you know focused on
china was really understanding that this
was going on
and when people think about this they
just think about the hackers they don't
think about the social engineering going
on and the profiling of the company
these these hacks can be very
sophisticated
in the way they work and in many ways
can have state-sponsored activity behind
them
you know in the case of some of the
companies i looked at it wasn't so much
as a cyber hack as it was a human hack
and you know they're using social
engineering i remember in one case
they basically found out that the guy
that had
the keys to the uh the servers
was actually a football fan a college
football fan
and so they crafted a newsletter for his
football team because they knew that he
got it and then
they embedded in that newsletter a link
that gave them access so many times
they're looking at facebook profiles of
these people twitter profiles
they're they're surveilling the company
who has access
and then they're trying to figure out
what can what does this person click on
what are their habits
so it's a really sophisticated uh human
engineering so it's social engineering
really and and
it takes a long time to really cultivate
targets
in in this manner it's just not like you
can
spam people but a lot of companies are
getting sophisticated in terms of what
they tell their employees about how to
be careful about things
some of the things i've seen have been
generally basically generated for the
person the single person
that they know that they can get access
to the system do we know
how uh this dark side hacker group
that's uh
uh from russia do we know how they
hacked into
the colonial uh pipeline has that come
out public
no i don't think so but i would imagine
it's some kind of social
my my guess uh would be that some kind
of social engineering they found out
uh somebody uh that they wanted to
target they
they sent them i would imagine some kind
of phishing mail
email and then they clicked on a link
that they probably shouldn't have
clicked on and and the company had
access
um through that it's very hard to just
uh break into a system most companies
have firewalls and everything else so
they're looking for somebody
to do something that prevent provides a
vulnerability that they can
exploit you know the thing that really
people ought to be concerned about is
not only is this happening to things
like colonial pipeline
uh we saw where um a um
probably a state sponsored um
hacker was trying to put chemicals into
water treatment in a city in florida
we've seen the christmas bombing in
memphis where it took down
first responders in this in the whole
cellular network for att in
tennessee for like two days uh last
christmas so
there's all kinds of infrastructure
attacks going on that
you know when you look across the in the
country we've got a big problem here in
terms of vulnerabilities
yeah that's very obvious and by the way
we're not talking about a small company
we're talking about
5500 mile pipeline
transports a hundred million
gallons of fuel a day this is a
sophisticated company it's not like
they're
they probably have cyber security
insurance they probably have the right
analyst they probably have the right
team in place so this could happen from
the smallest company to the biggest
company
we we've done these you know my wife
this will typically happen to us it'll
happen
at least once a week they'll get an
email saying
hey jennifer uh coming from me said hey
jennifer i just want you to know i
forgot your phone number can you please
email it to me so i can call you back
and jennifer will come and she'll say
babe did you email me this i said babe
why would i email you this this is
i'm your wife i'm your husband i know
your phone but they'll do this
and so many times so now we have a whole
team that
looks out for this but no matter what
you do they seem to still be
figuring out a way to how to get in
there what can companies do to prevent
this from happening
well it's really about um in teaching
their employees
uh to do just what you did which is or
your wife did
basically come and ask you did you
really send this if you have any
suspicion
first of all don't click on any links i
think that's the biggest thing you know
when i was in the pentagon
the joint staff got hacked and it was
basically somebody
clicked on a link in an email that they
shouldn't have clicked on
uh and then that that case it was uh it
was the russians that that we reported
that had done it but i mean this stuff
is going on all over the country i think
the the problem is
people don't realize how vulnerable
vulnerable our
infrastructure and our companies and our
government is to this type of thing
and we've looked at warfare through the
lens of you know f-35s and tanks and
ships and bombers and
i flew bombers but quite frankly warfare
is coming to our shores
into our own living rooms just like you
said into your wife's
uh email because this is the way that we
that we that we undermine our the
economic the social
and the political fabric of our society
today and that's what's going on in the
big time
by the way there was a guy named roger
robinson who worked in the reagan
administration
and they um what they did uh back in the
reagan administration is they s
they slipped into russia's supply chain
a valve that ended up creating the
biggest explosion
non-nuclear explosion in history was
witnessed by
our satellites in space in in the soviet
union
and so infrastructure attacks have been
going on through nefarious
means you know since the cold war what's
happening today
is that we've connected all of our
infrastructure and our companies to the
internet
and that means anybody at any time can
be attacked
today this this makes me uh this makes
me
think about i mean obviously you look at
the stats we've all read the stats 68
of gas stations in north carolina
reported fuel outages according to gas
buddy roughly half of all the gas
stations in georgia
south carolina washington dc and
virginia also reported outages
there was an interview done this morning
on fox business with mario bartroma
where john
casti matadis who's a billionaire says
the payments have been made to the
terrorists
i understand from my sources that four
million dollars was paid he's calling
them terrorists
i mean we don't know who these people
are and you know what
what makes me think about this as you go
into it okay so
gas prices beginning of the year around
225 they hit 303
that's a 40 increase 35 increase like
this
when you and i spoke last time i mean
we've spoken and you got
millions on top of millions of views
where you were speaking from experience
as the former senior director national
security council
do you think this is a you know because
they're saying
maybe this is because if you go on
darkside's website they'll say
here's our business model here's who
we've hacked before
here's who we've gotten money from we're
not political we're not religious
matter of fact we even have some values
and principles we don't target funeral
homes we don't target health and
there's certain things they don't do so
these are very value-based
criminals if you want to call them so
they're even telling you how they go
about doing business
do you think this is at all linked to
the man at the top
of putin who is you know encouraging
this to take place
or do you think this was just a couple
guys you know an organization that's
making money and this is their business
model
well i i mean that's the whole point
right we don't know and we don't even
know if it's the russians i mean
it could be uh coming from anywhere it
could be coming from within the united
states i mean that's the nature of
cyber attacks today um and you know so i
mean it's very hard to say
uh who it is or even what their
motivations are
like it's funny because you know we we
said that uh
all of a sudden uh the lockdown stopped
the coronavirus
in china you know we can't even believe
that so
i don't i would not believe anything
that these guys said because
we have no way of verifying that
information so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye